Unfortunately, Tokyo is always expensive,...
...but some seasons are worse than others.
Summer sees the most visitors so prices will be at their highest.
Tokyo summers are sweltering as well,...
...so if you don't like heat, it's best to visit in a different season.
On the other hand, winter can be quite cold,...
...but it doesn't freeze often and snow is uncommon.
Since there's plenty to do indoors in Tokyo, the winter isn't a bad time to visit.
If you do choose to visit during the winter,...
...just keep in mind that most restaurants, shops and museums will be closed...
...for the days surrounding the New Year.
The Golden Week holidays in early May should also be avoided for the same reason,...
...but if you visit earlier in the spring,...
...you may have a chance of seeing the cherry blossoms bloom.
This is a very popular time to visit,...
...so you may need to book in advance.
The cherry blossom season doesn't last long,...
...so research exactly when it's predicted to happen to make sure you don't miss it.
Tokyo's fall foliage is also stunning...
...and the fall lasts longer in Tokyo than many other places.
It will also be less crowded, as the summer tourists will have cleared out.
Spring and fall both have mild weather.
They may be the most pleasant times to visit Tokyo,...
...but it's easy to enjoy the city year-round.